hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar Quality Assurance is a
hematology laboratory presented by San
Westgard director of client services and
Technology Westgard quality control
I am Alexis Corrales of lappers and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by laberd's and brought to you
by Abbott Diagnostics to learn more
please visit Abbott comm now let's get
started before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentations
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left your screen I now present today's
speaker mr. Stan Westgard Stan Westgard
is the director of client services and
technology for Westgard quality control
mr. Westgard earned his MS degree in
computer science from Pace University
New York New York for more than 20 years
jen has managed the Westgard website
course portal and blog creating and
administering online training as well as
editing and writing hundreds of reports
essays and applications on quality
control method validation Six Sigma risk
management and other laboratory
management topics for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen then you may now begin your
presentation
all right thank you for that kind
introduction and welcome to today's hit
series sponsored by Abbott Diagnostics
the hit series our hematology and
hemostasis webinars and live
presentations designed to help
Abbot's customers learn more about
innovations and clinical approaches that
can support their laboratories goal in
achieving measurably better healthcare
performance my name is Stan Westgard and
today's topic is quality assurance in
the hematology laboratory
I want to begin of course with a
standard disclosure that Abbott
Laboratories is supporting my time and
my presentation there is a more
unorthodox disclosure that I should make
and that is particularly for those of
you attending a webinar you need to
understand which Westgard you are
hearing from there are two westgard's
but you may only be familiar with the
first Westgard I am known simply as a
Westgard whereas my father is known as
the u.s. guard so if you have heard of
the Westgard rules those are creation of
my father and I as you have been
following them for the last thirty years
I have only about 25 years in this field
whereas my father is actually
celebrating his 50th year of
contribution to laboratory medicine and
what we do in addition to training we
provide a series of resources through
the internet to laboratories worldwide
we have Westgard comm a membership site
that has more than 50 9000 laboratory
professionals it's a free membership and
if you join you get access to more than
600 different articles essays lessons
and so forth that have to do with
quality control we have a course portal
where we do structured training and we
have a blog where we cover shorter
articles things and news and most
importantly questions and answered the
agenda for today's a webinar starts with
a review of our current QC practices in
hematology after we do a review we'll
look at some frequently asked questions
and frequently floud 'add
recommendations when it comes to QC in
the hematology field and we'll even look
more closely at how common poor quality
control practices are in the hematology
area and then we'll suggest a solution a
next generation of quality control
practices which combine the power of the
Westgard rules with the power of Six
Sigma
and introduced the ability to actually
determine quantitatively your QC
frequency when we talk about hematology
in the laboratory there are a number of
papers that have come out in the last
decade that have called into question
the level of quality that's being
delivered so for instance this paper in
2010 was stating that many of today's QC
procedures are nonspecific in hematology
and they lead to non-productive
practices which is in congruence with
the fact that we have very advanced
engineering and some analyzers in
hematology that are in their fourth or
fifth generation
and another study that came out in 2012
looking at just Bazza phil count found
that three of the instruments out of
three so a hundred percent of the
methods that they looked at we're
providing unsatisfactory quality low
correlation between the count the Bazza
phil count of different instruments
between instruments and against
according to the reference method and
this can be of course something that is
not just important to the laboratory in
terms of its own ability to stay in
quality control but this can go out and
really impact patients in a dramatic
fashion so in a 2009 study looking at
the platelet measurement methods of
three different automated hematology
analyzers the study found that under
transfusion was observed with the use of
all of the analyzers that were studied
and of course under transfusion can be a
big problem for patient care
so we have papers going back a decade
that suggests quality is not quite as
given or as reliable in hematology
analyzers as we expect or definitely as
we would wish and there are some other
questions that come up when people adapt
what we might call the traditional QC
approach from clinical chemistry to the
special conditions of hematology
analyzers so some of the questions that
we frequently get on the West card
website are can I just use the
manufacturer's mean and standard
deviation when it comes to quality
control in hematology and I simply use
the manufacturers provided controls can
I just use the control ranges that are
provided on that package insert do I
have to use the Westgard rules in
hematology QC or should I avoid them and
then a very specific question for
hematology is our controls have such a
short life span isn't it too hard or too
difficult to establish the actual mean
and SD for those controls
when it comes to talking about the
manufacturers mean and standard
deviation we refer to iso one five one
eight nine and the technical requirement
states specifically the laboratory must
design internal kc systems that verify
the attainment of the intended quality
of results and that design means you
have to choose the control rules the
numbers of control and the frequency you
have to verify that the performance is
acceptable and you're trying to meet
some level of intended quality and that
intended quality usually is in the form
of an analytical performance
specification
manufacturers controls is not
recommended by ISO one five one eight
nine they intent in instead they
recommend using third-party independent
controls and that's just the latest
version of ISO one five one eight nine
where that recommendation was added and
typically ISO one five one eight nine
document Watchers will notice that if
something is recommended in this version
and it's an optional recommendation
that's a sign that the next version will
probably make it a mandatory requirement
so independent three party controls
becoming a mandatory requirement of any
ISO 151 eight nine laboratory that is
the future that we are headed toward the
the reason that even a document standard
like ISO one five one eight nine
recommends this third-party control it's
because there's too much evidence that
manufacturer controls get tweaked or
adjusted or manipulated and that the
control lot becomes synchronized to our
new reagent lot and that results in a
loss of the objective ability to detect
shifts and changes in clinically
important errors I'd like to tell people
that when you use a manufacturer control
sometimes what's happening is the
manufacturer is controlling you in
chemistry we have a very well recognized
problem of this where these manufacturer
controls are not very sensitive to real
errors and that's why in best practice
documents for the chemistry field it's
very well stated the best practice for
laboratories is to have third party
independent controls
can I just use the manufacturer control
ranges well here we can look at a clsi
document h26 and this is the second
accepted version and this is a standard
or I should say guideline that lists the
best practices for hematology Quality
Assurance in elaborate and in that clsi
says the laboratory must establish its
own expected mean and QC values over
covered control values published
manufacturer ranges are typically too
broad for effective QC and the problem
that happens when you use a
manufacturer's range is your limits will
typically be spread very wide from the
mean and it will make your limits look
very permissible and it'll compress your
data very very close to the mean it'll
give you an illusion that everything is
in control when in fact you may be
effectively practicing blindman QC
you're missing errors that are
clinically important but the way you've
constructed the levey-jennings control
chart makes it appear as if everything
is fine
another frequently asked question is
should I avoid using the Westgard rules
in hematology this often comes about
when we're talking about manufacturer
ranges and to standard deviation control
limits and there's a particular issue
when you use a full set of Westgard
multi rules on hematology QC charts
particularly the 10x rule
now the clsi guideline says multi rule
analysis which means Westgard rules it's
strongly recommended and also notes that
decisions based solely on plus or minus
two standard deviations are too
simplistic and they are insufficient and
then they quote West garden here again
they're probably quoting the Wesker not
myself a Westgard the traditional use of
1 2's warning control rule is no longer
recommended and instead the
recommendation is a hierarchical
selection of specific multi rules that
maximize PE d where PE d stands for
error detection and minimize PFR is
recommended using Six Sigma and power
function approaches at one sentence is
alluding to some advanced techniques
that we'll be introducing in the later
part of this webinar but essentially
it's saying don't use the 2's rule and
look at your Westgard rules but not
don't use them on everything don't use
all the Westgard rules on every
parameter but instead shape the approach
shape the number of rules you're going
to use based on the performance of the
method based on the needs of your
patient and how you'll determine what
the best fit is is by analyzing the
different rule sets and seeing which
gives you the highest error detection or
PD but also minimizes your false
rejection or your PFR and again the way
that you'll do that is by applying Six
Sigma approaches
our final question is about isn't it
just too hard to establish the mean and
standard deviation when my controls have
such a short lifespan and this is a
chronic problem for all hematology labs
where if you get one month of stability
that may be typical you're lucky if you
get two months of stability out of your
your hematology quality control so by
the time you've established or collected
20 data points which is usually the
minimum to establish your own mean and
standard deviation you're almost at the
end of the lifespan of that control so
one solution is to do an overlap of
controls so as the previous control lot
is ending then you start the new control
lot three to five days ahead of time and
during those three to five days you make
multiple measurements until you collect
that 20 data points in advance so by the
time last lot actually finishes you're
ready with a new mean and a new standard
deviation you can perform the switch
over to the new quality control a lot
and you actually have enough data to
keep going if you don't like that long
of an overlap another solution which is
to use just eight overlapped values so
that is you have the new control lot and
you run eight controls but and from that
you just calculate the new mean there is
a rule of thumb that eight values is
enough to reliably establish a new mean
it's not reliable enough to establish
your new standard deviation but if you
have the new mean you can use the old
coefficient of variation and make a
temporary set of new control limits you
can see the equation right there it's
the new mean times the old CV and that
gives you a temporary standard deviation
and you can use that on a temporary
basis to draw your control limits and
you should only use those temporary
control limits just long enough to
actually a
cumulate those 20 data points so you can
get the new mean I'm sorry you can get
the new standard deviation and then that
way you'll have the new mean the new
standard deviation you'll have all the
correct data to properly create your
control charts now a third solution is
to use a cumulative mean and standard
deviation from multiple control Lots and
if we look at the c24 guideline from
chemistry they say three to six months
cumulative out of cumulative values for
mean and standard deviation they give
you a reliable stable consistent
specification for mean and standard
deviation for solutions two and three we
are making an assumption that there's
not a lot of difference between each lot
of Hematology controls so if you see
that there is a big difference between
each lot of Hematology controls
solutions to and solutions three are
probably not appropriate because you're
going to get you you have very to two
different very performances and then if
you try and average those together or
cobble those together to give you
temporary control limits they're not
really giving you something that
reflects the real performance of either
that brings us to the end of the
frequently asked questions and now we're
going to look at how common poor quality
control practices are in hematology we
did a survey in 2016 we got responses
from over 900 labs for more than a
hundred countries now to be fair most of
the responses were from chemistry labs
but of those responses we got about a
hundred of them that were from
hematology laboratories or laboratories
that shared their hematology QC
practices with us so we can delve
closely into just how frequent problems
are in the hematology sphere and we can
see in the first question that about 70%
just under 70% of labs state that they
are using two standard deviation limits
for the hematology QC this is in
contrast to what we see in chemistry
where it's only about 55% so this is an
antiquated practice two standard
deviations is about 50 years old when
labs were just starting to do quality
control they used to sd limits
everything else in the lab of course has
changed but we seem to be burdened by
this legacy of history in this tradition
of using two standard deviations the
biggest problem with two standard
deviations is that it can give you a 5
percent 9 percent or a 14 percent
expected false rejection rate depending
on whether you're running one two or
three controls per run if you have
something as high as a 14 percent false
rejection rate you are spending most of
your time chasing ghosts these are
problems that you don't need to be
chasing down they don't actually
represent a real problem so this is a
technique you should abandon we also see
that about 70% of labs are using
Westgard rules for some tests and that's
almost in line with chemistry and
chemistry it's a bit higher about 78% of
the time labs are using what a chemistry
labs are using Westgard rules
and of course the benefit of these
Westgard rules is that they maximize
your air detection but minimize your
false rejection so think they still give
you the air detection that you might
like to have that the two se limits used
to give you but they don't have those
false rejection problems from the two SD
limits instead of 14% false rejection
you're down at like 1% or 2% or at most
three percent false rejection rate
when labs are choosing their control
ranges you can see there's two main ways
in this grunt in this chart that 56% of
labs report they use the manufacturers
range so that is the most common way
laboratory set up their QC is they just
use the manufacturers range so that that
thing that we told them they shouldn't
be doing that's what they're doing most
of the time but just behind that 53% of
labs also report they will actually
calculate the mean and standard
deviation this is in line with what we
see in chemistry as well although in
chemistry we see that more labs choose
their own mean and standard deviation do
that their own work then use the
manufacturers range so hematology is a
little bit behind in moving away from
manufacturer ranges when compared to
chemistry
when we look at the type of controls
that hematology labs are using nearly
80% of labs are just using the
manufacturers controls and this is much
higher than what we see in clinical
chemistry where it's only about
two-thirds
about 30% of labs are using third party
liquid acid controls and that's a little
bit lower than what we see in chemistry
where that number is 37% but when
interesting finding is this average of
normals QC or what some people call
patient data QC or what you may know as
both algorithm almost a quarter of labs
in hematology are using that cut type of
technique that patient data based QC
that's much higher than what we see in
chemistry it's half that it's only about
12% of labs in chemistry using that
technique and that technique is very
powerful and very useful so this is an
area where hematology is really the
leading area of the laboratory and when
it comes to patient QC
the labs run their QC
41% of labs and Emmett ology are just
running it once a day that's a little
bit lower than what we see in chemistry
chemistry it's 47% the other number that
we see that's pretty different is almost
a quarter of labs are running three
times a day or probably once a shift
that's almost twice as what we twice
what we see in chemistry so in chemistry
it's much more fixed that it's once a
day QC whereas a mythology partly due to
regulations is often encouraged to run
QC more than once a day
and what happens when laboratories in
hematology have an out of control event
how do they troubleshoot they're out of
control event
well 80% of them do what we want them to
do which is to troubleshoot to actually
seek the root cause and before they
consider rerunning a control they
actually try and find the source of the
problem but more than that 86% of labs
are actually just repeating the control
they see you a value that's out and they
cross their fingers and they hope that
by repeating it it will just fall back
in that numbers a little bit higher than
what we see in chemistry in chemistry
less than 3/4 of labs will repeat the
control but you can also see that if the
first repeated control doesn't work
there is six almost 60% of labs willing
to prepare and run a new control so that
is one control is out they repeat it
it's still out then they run a new
control and then 20% of labs will repeat
the new control is that still not in so
essentially they're running four times
to hope that a value will fall back in
and this repeating and repeating and
repeating responds we often call gambler
QC it's you're just trying to roll the
dice one more time and hope that the
numbers come up that make it appear like
you're back in
how often is this kind of out-of-control
event happening in hematology well 40%
of hematology laboratories report that
it's happening once day more than once a
day or once every few days so it's
happening quite frequently so all of
these problems that we see with
hematology QC because you are having so
many out of control events this is
really a burden to your laboratory
operations it wouldn't be so bad if yes
we repeat controls but we're only out of
control once a month we might be willing
to accept that kind of workaround or
that kind of imperfect protocol if it if
we weren't being so many out-of-control
results but if we have out of control of
control results every day or multiple
times per day then that's really telling
us we are overwhelmed by outliers we are
overwhelmed by alarms and what really we
risk is we may start going deaf we may
stop listening to these these alarms
because we get them so often this is a
condition that's been well known in
clinical circles particularly with
electronic health records when you hear
about alert fatigue that typically
describes what happens when a clinician
gets too many pop-up arrow
warnings they get so many warnings they
just get used to clicking them and
dismissing them and they actually will
miss a very important alarm the same
thing can happen in our QC we get so
many QC alarms that we consider to be
opus isn't a real problem we'll just
repeat the control it'll fall back in
but in fact there may be a real out of
control situation that is going to
impact patients and we miss it we
dismiss it because we think oh it's just
another one of those false rejections
and this corrosive problem means that we
get labs that will report patient
specimens will report patient results
even though their QC has told them that
they are out of control
so here it's about 9% of labs will
report patient results despite being out
of control daily weekly or monthly and
that is actually a little bit less than
what we see in in the chemistry we see
this happening one in ten labs are
reporting this reporting results when
we're out of when they're out of control
question that we have asked Labs in the
survey is have you actually changed how
you do QC and 78% of labs in the
hematology area have said no we've made
no what no changes to how we wrote our
QC it's the same kind of kc we've been
doing for the last 10 years or 20 years
or 30 years and this is higher than what
we see in hematology and chemistry more
than 61 percent of labs say that they
haven't made any changes but it's not as
high as 78% so pretty much it looks like
QC practices have been in a kind of
stasis or status quo for quite a while
and a lot of poor habits as accumulated
now that we've catalogued all of our
problems and really explored how
prevalent those problems are we want to
move on to suggesting some solutions and
just as you probably installed or added
a next-generation hematology instrument
to your laboratory we're going to
introduce a next-generation type of QC
and that's going to be more than just
the Westgard rules it's going to be
Westgard rules plus the addition of the
Six Sigma technique and then something
that we've just added in the last year
is the ability to determine
quantitatively scientifically the QC
frequency just how often you need to run
QC the core of the Six Sigma approach is
to
benchmark your quality on this zero to
six scale
there's a universally accepted scale
from zero to six on the Sigma
performance benchmark and Six Sigma is
world-class performance and that is less
than four defects per million reportable
z' so if you have a million test results
and you're at Six Sigma then less than
four of those results are expected to be
defective or in error or to be false
positives or false negatives this is
essentially almost defect free and what
you'll find is if you are at Six Sigma
your laboratory operations become more
efficient your test results become more
effective because your clinician knows
and is very confident that those results
are reliable and accurate the other end
of the Sigma scale is typically
considered three sigma that is the
minimum acceptable performance is three
sigma and that corresponds to about
sixty seven thousand defects per million
reportable z' and outside of health care
if you're at three sigma or lower
industry and manufacturers would be
thinking about radically improving or
redesigning or even replacing any
process that has performance that
problematic a three sigma or a two sigma
process really consumes too much time
and money and effort from a laboratory
or manufacturer or any kind of
industrial process you're really
generating too many defects which causes
you to do more troubleshooting to spend
more time tracking down redoing your
work having to do multiple tests to get
one correct answer it really ends up
being too expensive to maintain such a
low sigma process and of course because
there are so many defects many of those
could get out and reach patients and
impact them in adverse ways
when we make the application of Six
Sigma to hematology when we're talking
about the analytical tests we need a
number that tells us how good each
parameter needs to be in other words for
leukocytes how good do we have to be in
order to provide accurate results and
support the best patient care there are
many different sources of these quality
requirements or analytical performance
specifications for instance in this
first column you see CLIA those are the
US regulations and it directly regulates
one two three four five different
parameters in Germany there are the
really buck rules and they specify in
your laboratory comparison goals four
four there is something called a Rico's
database and the most recent version
that we have available was was published
in 2014 and based on biological studies
they can specify for almost every
parameter in hematology how good you
need to be to be as good as possible
given the the known variation that the
body introduces to those laboratory
tests then the final column is actually
a kind of consensus statement from
Spanish EQA or proficiency testing
groups they looked at the actual
proficiency testing results of their
member laboratories and tried to figure
out what are those labs capable of
achieving they're trying to figure out
if there are some goals that are so
small no one can hit them or what's a
more practical goal what can today's
technology achieve and so out of all of
those different resources we make a
recommendation for your your common
parameters use a CLIA goals for your
differential counts you're going to be
using the Rico's goals and then there
are some times where you're going to
want to rely on the Spanish consensus
goal many of the Rico's goals for
leukocytes and erythrocytes and
hemoglobin
in hematocrit those goals are so small
that really no method on the market is
capable of achieving those at something
like four five or six sigma so maybe the
next generation of instrumentation will
be able to hit those goals but it's not
something that we should expect to see
in the next few years once we have those
allowable total error goals we can then
use that as the context and we introduce
our bias and our imprecision and that
allows us you can see at the bottom of
the slide to calculate our Sigma score
our Sigma metric is the allowable total
error which was on the previous slide
and then we subtract the absolute
percentage bias which we might be
getting from our peer group or our EQA
/pt program or our comparison of our
actual control mean versus the target
mean and then we divide that number by
the imprecision or CV which is of course
what we get routinely from our controls
and what you have in front of you is a
Westgard Sigma rules so it's the
traditional Westgard rules but you see
there are some vertical blue lines that
divide the Westgard rules into different
Sigma zones and so if you're at the Six
Sigma zone you'll notice that the blue
line comes up and there's really only
one Westgard rule you need to use so if
you have a sixty sigma hematology method
you don't really need all the Westgard
rules you can set your limits at one
three s or three standard deviations
from the mean and then if you look lower
below that Six Sigma number it gives you
an estimated run size and it says one
thousand patient samples
well that means every 1000 patient
samples you should probably run QC
that's the way to minimize the risk of
impacting even one patient result with a
clinically significant error
and then as you look across horizontally
as you go to five Sigma that run size
drops to about 450 for Sigma it drops
203 Sigma it drops to 45 so you can see
that as you have more more Sigma you do
QC less frequently with fewer rules but
as your Sigma goes lower
you will need more Westgard rules and
you will need to run more frequently
your life gets harder the lower your
Sigma gets
to conclude I want to give you this
message that we really need to make
improvements in how QC is practice in
hematology there are many common
counterproductive practices in the field
right now and we should be moving away
from those manufacturer controls
manufacturer ranges and interference
that should be avoided and we should be
moving towards your own mean your own
standard deviation and third-party
independent controls and if you have Six
Sigma performance or five Sigma or even
four Sigma you will get some real
benefits by applying this more advanced
technique of combining Westgard rules
with Six Sigma and then modifying your
QC frequency we see in chemistry and we
expect to see in hematology soon as we
apply this in labs around the world that
those Six Sigma parameters they get
financial benefits from the reduction of
the number of Westgard rules that are
implemented from the reduction in the
number of controls that need to be run
and really you will see a reduction the
number of outliers that are flagged by
your system because there are many many
flags that you might think we're errors
that now will not become clinically
significant you will not consider them
to be real errors you might see a 10 X
but if your method is four or five or
six Sigma that 10 X violation actually
is not that important and for hematology
that's a really good thing because that
10 X is probably one of the most common
errors or common problems that they see
as a controls reach the end of their
lifespan they begin to drift and shift
and now we have a way to say that mat
shift might happen but we're not going
to have to worry that we need to reject
the run because of it we have a way to
adjust ourselves because we know so much
about the performance
the method and with that I want to
conclude this part of the presentation
and I want to open it up to questions so
now if you haven't already submitted a
question I would love to take your
questions and have a dialogue about
other issues you see in hematology QC
thank you very much
Thank You Stan for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer a question
box located on the far left your screen
will answer as many questions as we have
time for so let's get started our first
question is the difference between lots
can we assess the difference between
lots using vendor provided values as the
basis
that's a very good question and I think
this is a question that not only
pertains to hematology but really every
discipline within the laboratory and the
most recent recommendations on lot to
lot changes and assessing them really
push the important decision making tools
onto patient samples so it's not that
you want to use what's in the package
insert that's really a vague guideline
what you want to do is take sometimes
it's ten patient samples from the
previous lot that have already been
tested and then you retest them on the
new reagent lot and you compare the
differences in those two results and if
those differences exceed what you've
defined as a critical difference then
you now have a you know an evidenced
based observation that the new reagent
lot is significantly different and
significant usually you set that
difference to be something that's almost
clinically significant and that point
and at that point if you have that
signal you start thinking about the
manufacturer of the of the reagent and
you see is there a fix that can be made
to that reagent or is there a different
reagent that could be provided that
would be more appropriate and when they
say a critical difference that can be
more easily understood as it's going to
be a fraction of the allowable total
layer so we're pretty familiar with
allowable total errors we can figure out
maybe it's going to be a half maybe it's
going to be a third of that allowable
total error that's considered an
acceptable bias in between the two
reagent Lots and if it exceeds that
one-half to one-third of the allowable
total error then that's you're really
shifting the values too high
now then you suggested eliminating the
one to drool but for a tutus failure
requires both to be out doesn't that
make both run suspect well I guess I
would make a distinction between what is
a 1 to s rule and a 2 to s rule so a 1
to s rule is as we as we would define it
it's a single value outside two standard
deviations and again the problem with
that is most of the time when that
happens there's absolutely nothing wrong
with method it's simply a false
rejection and the false rejection rate
with one control is around 5% with two
controls it's just under 10% with three
controls it's around 14% so a 14% false
rejection rate ends up being just really
overwhelming to a system now the two 2's
rule that is a good rule that when
necessary if you have two values that
are outside two standard deviations on
the same side that's not going to happen
very often and when it does happen it's
going to indicate a problem so we're not
suggesting eliminate that eliminating
the two 2's rule that's one that should
be in your arsenal of QC techniques but
the one 2's rule that's really a half
century old and it's antiquated and we
should be moving on to something that's
more advanced
manufacturer provided upper and lower
limits are already very narrow for
example plus or minus 0.5 difference
from the need for hemoglobin can we use
these cut-offs the it's interesting that
in many cases the manufacturers range is
often complained of as too wide not too
narrow and remember that the
manufacturers range it's built on the
variation of many many laboratories so
typically the problem is there's so much
variation in all the laboratories that
they that they sampled that your range
is your standard deviation is quite
large and therefore your your
manufacturer range is quite wide and
it's it would be wider than what you see
in any individual laboratory so
typically the manufacturers range is
really only supposed to give you a
beginning helpful idea of this is
somewhere within this range your actual
mean should fall you should find your
actual mean within this manufacturers
range and if you don't then it's a
signal that however you're operating
you're outside the expectation of all
the other labs the manufacturers range
is not meant to be your QC rain
they are not meant they're not meant
that you write them down as oh these are
my control limits and I'm going to use
them for the rest of my QC operations in
the absence of having any information at
all about the performance of your
control then yes it's a very temporary a
very temporary use of the manufacturers
range could be acceptable but that would
be really do you think about it so when
you first have an instrument and you
first have that control and you have no
historical information at all that's
when you would use the manufacturers
range if you're finding that the
manufacturers range is too small it you
know again what you should be doing is
figuring out your own range is putting
together enough data so that you know
your own mean
your own standard deviation and then you
can draw your own control limits and if
your control limits are wider than the
manufacturers range that is acceptable
that is okay I would say it's rare that
I've heard of a scenario where the
manufacturers range is tighter than the
labs actual range but it's not I suppose
on paper that's not something that could
not happen it's just rare that it would
happen
now our next question how can 86% just
repeat the control but 80% troubleshoot
appropriately are these the same lap all
right so that that goes back to the
question of how we were conducting our
survey and and we were asking
laboratories what do you do and we
explicitly allowed for some questions
multiple answers so they could labs
could say well I actually do
troubleshoot but if you're thinking
about your full hematology menu we're
not asking you to to answer on just one
test we're saying overall are there
tests where you really do troubleshoot
or are there tests where you actually
just repeat the control so we allow the
labs to answer as many times as possible
so some labs will say yes on some tests
I do the right thing and on other tests
I do the wrong thing where I'm just
gamble I'm doing the gambler approach to
QC and I just repeat the controls over
and over and over so that it could we
don't have the granular ability to rule
out that these are different labs making
those responses but obviously since the
percentage is so high there's a lot of
labs that say well I do do the right
thing sometimes but I also do the wrong
things just as frequently
ladies and gentlemen we are getting so
many good questions today so just as a
reminder we will any questions that we
do not have time for will be answered by
the speaker via the contact information
that you provided at the time of the
registration so Steph let's continue in
a stable system a 2 to s situation is
expected once every 400 samplings
if this happens more than that how can
you call that a false alarm
that's an interesting question again
we're getting back to the two 2sd rule
which in our previous question we
definitely did not want to rule out as a
possible rule that could be used and now
we hit the idea of the expected false
rejection rate whereas what will be your
observed rejection rate so through
simulation studies with any particular
QC rule we and this was some of the
pioneering work by the Westgard was to
figure out what is the expected false
rejection rate of any of our particular
control rules and so we might be able to
say the two 2's rule we would expect one
out of 400 runs there will be a
rejection and then that but while we
might expect that it comes along once
every 400 runs in reality the way
probability works is it doesn't wait
that exact amount you might get to false
rejections within 10 runs and you won't
know it it's just you know the way the
way random things work you don't they
don't come on a schedule so if you see
multiple 2 2's violations it's still
entirely possible that those are false
rejections and they just happen to be
clustering in us in an unusual way
so we even when we know these rates or
these percentages of fault expected
false rejection that doesn't mean we can
therefore say within a given time frame
if we see more than one of those
rejections it's either false
or not a false resection whenever
rejection occurs on any rule we have to
assume it's a real rejection until we
can rule that possibility out until we
do the troubleshooting and say well none
of these other things are wrong so it
looks like that particular rejection
there's no reason for it we will
therefore call it a false rejection
now if you are calculating your own
reference ranges in one test falls
outside the main structures range how do
you proceed
okay now I think we have to I'll make an
assumption when the when we're saying
reference range we are mean meaning
control range if it was a if you've
truly established your own reference
range and then you have a value fall
outside your reference range that's
something that might not be taken into
account
during your QC monitoring stage it might
be happening during the clinical
interpretation stage but let's go with
the idea that you've established your
own control range but the control range
is different than what you see on the
manufacturers range and again the
manufacturers range is giving you an
idea of where your mean should lie it's
not defining how a broad range within
which your control range must also fall
so you could have a mean that's still
within the manufacturer's range but then
the actual control range might tip above
or below what where the manufacturer's
range is that is it completely
acceptable so that would not be
something that you would want to be
concerned about that's just that that's
just the way the system has been set up
now is there added value of doing QC for
calculated hematology parameters like
MCD MCHC MCH etc
those do add quite a bit of value on
particularly those and those indices
become they're very strongly controlled
and very predictable so when you see
something go wrong on an Indus that's
usually a sign something's very wrong
and if we think about another use of
those indices if we think about Bo's
algorithm if we think about the use of
patient values there are some parameters
in hematology that are uniquely suited
suitable for a closer monitoring of the
patient values and in fact as I as I
mentioned earlier hematology labs are
twice as likely to be using a kind of
average of normals or moving averages or
a patient data QC technique and the
benefit of that is no wolf one of the
benefits is you don't have to buy
controls in order to use that technique
so it's very efficient it's also very
close to the patients and it also is
providing you a real-time monitor of the
QC process so if you think that we might
have methods that are at Six Sigma which
means we actually reduce our QC
frequency to quite you know to once per
thousand patients well in between 1,000
patients and our QC events at either end
of those it will feel comforting to
everyone if we have a moving average or
a patient data kind of QC that's
monitoring all of those moments within
the QC bracket
now our next question is the
sigh h26 a 2 and cap checklists speak to
the relative uselessness of low-level
controls and hematology in the USA only
two levels are required would you
comment on that so yeah there are
they're not only just in hematology
tests but there are some some cases in
other disciplines I might actually think
about your infectious disease and your
some of your screening assays where the
low level control it starts to reach the
level of it's almost a blank it's almost
it should give you absolutely no signal
at all and very difficult for you to
develop a good normalize distribution
one of the things that we try and take
into account when we're doing Six Sigma
benchmarking is choosing the best
control level and often if it's a case
where that low level control has no
utility we will say don't even bother
this calculating a Sigma metric down for
that level figure out you know if
there's a low positive or there's
another the middle or the high level of
control is actually where you make
critical medical decisions that's where
it's important to figure out Sigma
metric now in terms of how many control
levels you need the Sigma metric
response signal metric calculation will
help you determine just how many levels
are necessary or optimal to do QC so it
could be you're running three levels
right now but if you find out you have a
Six Sigma method then you could look at
what are this what are the QC procedures
that have just two levels of control and
how do they provide will they provide me
enough quality control enough error
detection to adequately monitor this
method and then that will explicitly
allow you to move away from a three
level control to two level control
because you can then demonstrate well
there's two level control and
however whatever controllers we set up
that provides me with enough air
detection to fund to detect any really
medically important air but I don't need
a third level of control to do it so
obviously you have to check your
regulations because some regulations
somewhere in the world will say for
hematology you need three levels of
control regardless of the utility of
those individual levels but if as the
question suggests in in the USA two
levels are sufficient then you can
figure there is an evidence-based way
for you to move away from a three level
control to and then justify why you've
gone to a two level control and see what
metrics can help you do that
you
we have a de analyzers Sheldon Ruby and
we use controls provided for Evans but
these controls are manufactured for
struck do you consider this can excuse
me do you consider these controls as a
third part a third part control alright
that's a great question because um you
know there's this very strong emphasis
on having a third party or independent
control and um some manufacturers will
do a bundling where is where they're
getting a control from a third party
vendor and they're just including it
with their instrument we would count
that as an independent control where it
becomes a and not an independent control
is where the manufacturer or the person
who's providing it to you um the person
who's providing it to you with the
instrument it has actually built the
control themselves and had a hand in
setting its expected value and often I
guess I have too many anecdotal pieces
of evidence where the manufacturers
control gets tweaked adjusted somehow
its range gets changed so that as a new
reagent lot comes out the manufacturers
recommendations for the control lot also
change and what happens is there may be
a change in the reagent lot but the
control has been adjusted so that you
won't be able to detect that change and
really it comes down to incentives of
the manufacturer where since they don't
make any money on the control side all
of their effort and their incentive is
to minimize the number of problems and
phone calls and complaints that are
generated by the use of that control and
so they will typically want as wider
range as possible and when you call in
technical support they'll say did you
run the control is it within our range
if it's within our range then we say
it's fine
even though we already understand
the range that they have settled that
set on is too wide
there's just they they are finding ways
to control their customers not
necessarily control their method
now it looks like we do have time for a
couple more questions let's keep going
how does these new excuse me how to be
really a line with regulations imposed
by by CLIA
by CLIA so the new recommendations I
suppose what we have to understand is
that the clear regulations which are
probably some of the more specific
regulations in the world they really
only require you to do some QC they
don't necessarily say by the way you
should use these limits and these rules
so what the what our problem has been I
suppose with CLIA is that they haven't
been specific enough and inspectors will
simply ask lab you know effectively an
inspector in a laboratory in the US
they look to see if you have a chart
that has lines on it
and dots on it and if you can say yes
see this it's a chart has horizontal
lines it has dots that are you know all
over this chart then the inspector will
say okay you you're doing your QC job
they really don't often get down to the
level of specification where they ask
you okay I see you're doing these set of
limits can you prove to me that that's
adequate for this method or can you
prove to me that you're detecting a
medically important error with the QC
procedure you've implemented on this
test they never get that specific so but
these tools fill in that that gap of
saying yes I know you're doing some QC
now let's figure out how to get you to
do the right QC and sometimes the right
QC is less stringent than what you're
currently doing and in some cases it
will be the opposite you you might be
using two standard deviation limits and
when we do an objective analysis of the
test performance we'll realize wow you
actually need to do Westgard rules and
think about increasing the frequency of
how often you do QC so we are not
it's these new techniques we're really
filling in a gray area or a gap in the
regulations so it's not that this will
change how you get inspected it's simply
that you will have more confidence as
you operate and as you report results
you
now we run approximately 9000 samples in
24 hours using six sigma you'd have to
run QC nine times within 24 hours and
use the Six Sigma that does not seem
logical for us in the size of the lab
can you comment on this um well I was
showing you the the simplified QC
frequency suggestions if you have a Six
Sigma method you may and you actually
use what we call a Six Sigma QC
frequency nomogram so there's a much
more granular tool that will give you
less it won't give you a simplified
recommendation it'll give you a more
exact recommendation and this this
approach is really only two years old so
we're still finding we're still also
trying to understand the consequences
and implications it could be at a Six
Sigma method you could be going to once
every 3,000 or 4,000 or 5,000 patient
samples and I think so it's not that
you're let's not get stuck on once per
1000 in terms of doing the QC minimum if
you're just doing one set of QC so
you're doing two levels or three levels
of control in the morning and then you
do 9000 patient samples and then you
consider running QC again well we're
probably going to say that may be a
situation where you want to increase the
QC frequency if only because of what's
the downside when you're out of control
if you go 9000 patient samples and then
you find out you're out of control how
do you retest 9000 samples
the risk to patients um if we go
almost 10,000 based examples before we
do any kind of check amantha very at the
very least I would say if you've got
your QC frequency down to multiple
thousands in between your QC events I
would strongly recommend having those
moving averages with Bulls algorithm or
the patient data QC monitoring some of
those methods so that if in real time
you can see one of your patient moving
averages start to dip or spike that
gives you the beginnings of a heads up
on there may be an analytical problem
occurring and we need to run some we
need to run some controls at this moment
to figure out if we're still in control
or for not
now what are your thoughts of an iqcp
for Hematology due to lack of variations
between lots a lot
so iqcp this individualized quality
control plan on now if we bear in mind
that the the these really were invented
to try and help justify a lunar based QC
frequency for most point-of-care devices
that is we have point-of-care devices
where they want to just run QC once a
month and they couldn't figure out a
real scientific way to justify it so
they came up with a document approach
which is the individualized quality
control plan and if you if you put iqcp
on the top of a document and then you
have a table of contents that has three
components error risk assessment a QC
plan and the quality assessment plan
then you can make any QC frequency
decision that would be reduced from once
a day the QC frequency recommendations
we we tend to say the iqcp is currently
structured it uses risk analysis as
cover to come up with an arbitrary
decision because most labs that were
doing once a month QC they went through
their iqcp and at the end of it they
decided they were still going to do once
a month QC so that iqcp process really
was a lot of paperwork it wasn't a lot
of science and it wasn't a lot of
judgment now the approach that we're
talking about about QC frequency where
you actually call on the Curt parven
model which looks at the maximum risk to
patients the max enough variable that is
a scientific data driven reproducible
way to determine your QC frequency if
you can reduce your QC frequency based
on that model which is what we
incorporated into the Six Sigma QC
frequency nomogram and what we put on
that last slide of the
Westgard Sigma rules that's a
data-driven way to reduce your QC
frequency and that that would be what we
would consider evidence-based and
acceptable
we have gotten so many good questions in
today we're still getting more we are
this we are going to wrap it up with
this one right here yeah when do I want
your meat oh I would say because you
know there are a lot of Westgard portals
out there I'm going to be copying down
these questions the ones that I didn't
answer and if you can be patient and
give me a day or two they will pop up
all the questions plus some answers on
one of the Westgard websites
perfect when setting up your mean and SD
years ago I was informed that the
bidding must be a number within the
manufactures data control range is this
true yes your mean should fall within
the manufacturers range if your mean is
falling outside the manufacturers range
essentially they're saying we've looked
at a lot of different labs and we've
come up with a range of expectations and
you're outside that range of
expectations you're significantly away
from the herd and if you think some many
of those recommendations are tend to be
instrument specific and sometimes they
could be even peer group specific down
to the same lot of reagent then you
really shouldn't be behaving so
differently from the rest of your peer
group or the rest of the you know the
rest of the laboratory herd so if you do
find yourself outside of that you need
to start investigating if there is a
reason why you've drifted so far away
Thank You stem do you have any final
comments for our audience well I would
you know I would say I suppose this is
something everybody in hematology
already knows but typically when we when
we talk about Casey we will say well you
know each discipline will say that
they're different but most of the time
they're not different it's just a
question of changing like the context or
the expectation the biggest challenge
with hematology is that lifespan of
controls and that really is different
than anything else we see in laboratory
testing I hope I've tried to give you
some coping mechanisms for dealing with
short short life's life cycle of the
controls but it is I think within our
power to still manage hematology
parameters within the same level of
quality that we see in other areas even
though we are hampered by a short
lifespan of our controls and thank you
again for to all of you from so many
different places in the world who tuned
in for this lab roots from a webinar and
I hope we'll able be able to do
something like this again soon
thank you against ten for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to make glaber's and our
sponsor abbott diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions we've
received so many great questions today
due to the amount of questions that we
were unable to answer due to time
constraints Abbott and Sun will be
sending out the email with information
of where you can view these questions
and answers don't forget you may
continue to submit questions during the
on-demand period this webcast is
viewable on demand through February of
2019 leverets will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thanks again for
joining us goodbye